THERE.
LIOD, AFTER A BUSYEEK
FOR YOURG. ATION
>>> RUSSLACED
APTO TTIONSI TUTPO AIR THEWHFUSV
THN .
NEARLY 1,500 PROTESTERAICALLP, -
T THAT IN QUOTES --
ONWE
VEISMISSED THIS AS
E THIS TES
JOINING TITY ANALYST AND FORMEA
CHIEF  RUSSIA , HALL.
D FORMER UAGEN
STEVE, THAT NIECE THAT THE THIS
SW>> I THINK VLADIMIR
IMPROVE IO ANTS TO
PARTTHNGARING THE D, NOT
E, B AUA
GETTING A GUY LIKE FEIMINISTER R
NATO ATTACKING RUSSIA.
TH INLY THAT
IN TO GE
F NATITO
TRY TO Y MEN
S  WHICHO FAS KIA US MEN. PART L
AT THE>>AN YOU
WHAT WWEO KYLIE
BUT ALLOO H K, VEOD.WH NING HE
.
CT THAT THEREXCHANOOD
REMORE
G OUT
OF HAND.
ANKIES I
DANGEROUS TO THE EXISTENCE OF
THE
AND THAT'S WT I'VEEEFOR QUITE S.
>> BEE
FOAINE.E, WE KNOW WHICH WAY THIS
GOINGM
WHNKRT  RUS
OS AYL RIGHT, YOU N
PREDE TN PRES RUSSIA.
TO CLAI
THE DONBAS REGIONS ALSO THE M
OOWRUN TERRITORY
BECAUSE THE PELEHE SD,US.
OLUTELIT
THE UKRA WILL
NOT SICKAY, AY, WE T ITW THAT'S
E.ODTHIS S G
SERIOUS ESCALATION.Y TAKE LAND W
RUSSIA, YOU
THE INTERNAONDOIN A E KREMLI D.
E THEY WANT US TO BE VERY
WORRIED ABOUT THIST TO THE
BUT I WOD  SURPRISED AT  THAWEE
ANNEXEY AFFINISH THEIR REFEREND
>> PUTIN SAYING THEY'RE
BLUF.F S ANNOCE THIEK
AT
POSSIBLY MORE,RE GOING TO  LL FT
THESE INCREDIBLE SCEATORR,S TO U
CAIATO,
JA, R IT'S B BROAD.
COUNUNLDEEING RUSSIANSO GET IN
OLSTEROR UKRAINE?
>> W NOT?
BUT LET'S NOTIMATE
RENG
AL IS LECTIONS, THIS IS --YSINCI
OF HIS
THE MOBILIE GUYS IN THATTE, ON I
GOG TO GO THROUGH APPARENTLY
IR
IMPACT, IF YOU THINK THAT THEN
THE FIGHT?THE ONE HA I
, TIME T UP AND AINED PROPERLY .
I THINTHAT T PPLMEERS THAT THER
LY  HAVE DONENGS --
RY TO M IT
THFIELD.
SO THAHELP.
BUT A N  EARLIER ON
TWITTER WHO I THINK CAPTURED I
VERY WELL.
HE SAID, LOOK,E MOST PAR PORTIO
ARMYT O FIEL
AGAINST USWHENCALL-U
GUYS, IT
EASIER FOR US.HAM QUITE THAT
I IL IT.
ADNSM ALSO QUITE THISNOT
GOYOKN
END-ALAN THE
RUSSIANS HOPIT'S GOINGBE.
>> STEVE DID TOUCH ON IT THE
DOMESTICE ,
L KINDOFID
E SOLDIERSEMSELVESIO, THEI
RSE, NO ONWA GT.
HOW MUCHISG TO RE INSI
AND CAUSE PRESIDT PUN OBLEMS?
THERE'A LOKNOW, THE RUSSIA T HAB
DOESN'T
I MEAN, THE MAJORITY- JO O
PROPAGANDA THAT THE WEST
INS  UKR NAZIS THE
IF YOU REPEA OVEOVER AND OVER A.
EE RUBBER